It seems early that early to
push a lawn mower. That's not,
I didn't have a lawnmower job when
I was 11. That seems early. No,
I don't think so. I think it's, you know,
you tell them where not to put their
feet in their hands and they're good.
Let the little fella have a
life kind of involved in sports.
They will play, they will play a lot of
Lacrosse. You play a lot of basketball.
They shovel snow yet. Swim team.
Yeah. They shovel snow. Get out there.
The 10 year old, the eight year
olds shovel snow during the winter,
six year olds like, yeah. Mugs.
He's not doing a lot. Got It.
Figured out a way out of this shit.
He's going to be management.
I think that's what he's gonna do. He's
gonna be management somehow. Uh, but uh,
yeah. The, the, the work ethic. I think
you're absolutely right. I mean we, every,
every generation,
right?
Like my parents wanted it to be
easier for me and my brothers. Right.
And their parents, I'm sure want it
to be easier for them, right. Nobody.
And so you do that,
but eventually you get to diminishing
returns because it becomes so easy.
And you know,
the kids forget what it is like to
actually have to work for something to
compete and to compete. And
you know, we can't all, it's,
it's like that I saw some story,
not that I troll the social media,
but there was a story that popped
up that, uh, some community, uh,
they had a cheer squad tryout and one
of the girls didn't make it on cheer
squad.
I didn't even know what cheer squad,
I guess the cheerleaders and the mom was
upset and so she went and complained.
And so the school decision was that
everybody who tried out gets to be on this
squad. Yeah. You can imagine
what that looks like.
That's a,
you got to teach kids the opposite.
That if you didn't do good enough,
you need to figure out what you did wrong
and go back and improve and work on it.
And then if you do get in next year,
you'll get an amazing feeling
of accomplishment rather
than an amazing feeling
of entitlement. Right. You, you belong
in everything you try out for. Well,
that's going to be a big fat wake up
call when you go out to compete in the
workforce.
Right. Nobody's going to,
oh my God, nobody, nobody's
going to cut you any slack.
Theoretical fully. Yeah, but no, that's,
that's, that's right. The idea that,
you know, you got to
you, I mean it's like my,
my two older boys who are people thinking,
okay,
Mike's now talking about his kids
all the time. Uh, my two little boys,
I have gotten to the point now where the
sports thing and they play and if they
don't play well, they sit right.
Because earlier than that, you know,
everybody plays right. It's
equal playing time. You know,
that's what you typically go get the
coaches here and that's a good thing.
They little kids are learning how to play
the game of where to stand and all the
rest of it. So, but then
they get to a certain point,
it becomes merit based
or it should anyway,
which is how it works in Idaho basically,
at least with the teams that were we
were associated with, is that if you're,
if you don't play that well then
maybe you don't make the team.
And if you made the team and you're not
playing as well as the other kids and
you're sitting on the bench.
And so you know, my kids,
you don't know when it first started
happening, you know, they were just,
they were complaining, you
know, like, you know, screw it,
I'm not getting any playing time.
And I'm thinking, well, okay,
what's the next part of that thought
process that you need to work your way
through?
If you're not getting enough playing time,
it's because you're not what planning
as well as you should be compared to the
other kids. Therefore,
what do you need to do?
So you have to walk them
through this process.
And that's okay because kids don't
know this stuff inherently. Maybe.
And so you teach them that, but you
don't teach them that while you're,
you're right. Why don't you
try a different sport, or
you know, or you're right,
we should talk to the
coach about your parents.
They're making it too difficult for the
children and they're not having a good
time. And it should be about companionship
and it shouldn't be about competition.
Well, you're setting your kid up for
failure because it can be about both.
It can be about companionship, but also
about competition and, right. Oops. Look,
the world's competition, it's filled with
it. If you're not competing, if you're,
if you just decide you don't want to
have anything to do with competition,
that's your choice. But if you engage in
something that does require competition,
you want special access.
Right?
Right, right. It does. Yeah. If you
don't, if you're not that nature,
if you don't have that competitive
side of you and okay, fine,
but then don't go through the
rest of the life thinking what?
Just because life is a competition,
which you know,
may upset you when you find that out,
that you don't get special dispensation
just because you're not a competitive
person. It does it. Yeah. So I agree
with it. Participation Trophies,
all the nonsense that's going on today.
Well, I was, I was, uh, I was walking,
one of my boys, the oldest went off the
off the lacrosse field not too long ago.
And he said, how'd I do? And I said, well,
you could've done better. You could have
played harder. He just wasn't into it.
Right.
He was tired or whatever.
So he kind of looked at me and I didn't
realize I was walking and there were
some parents around me.
And as we were walking across the field,
and so he kind of looks at me and I
knew what he was thinking, which is Dan,
that's not right. And so
I looked at her, I said,
do you want me to be honest with you and
you want me to just stand here and blow
smoke up your ass?
And I found out afterwards that a couple
of parents who are upset about the fact
that I would say that, but he knew
exactly what I meant. And he said,
now you should be
honest. And I said, well,
the parents were upset at you for
being honest. Yeah, yeah, exactly. And,
and you know, it'd be fair Muggsy the
youngest one got called in for, uh, uh,
I tell you this, he got caught if
using the word Douche bag one time,
but a funnier,
funnier one was when he and two of
his buddies who shall not be named,
who were out in the playground not too
long ago and there was sitting down in,
they're playing some game, right?
It was recess. And all the kids,
all the different grades are
out there running around.
And everybody knows my little kid,
you know,
Mugsy he's like the mayor of
the town. He's, he's just a
jolly happy guy. He's got,
he's got us, he's going to be the guy
that takes 10 years to get out of college.
Right? And so he, he and his two
little buddies are sitting there,
they're playing some game where they
got to count with their fingers.
So at one point, Jack has the number
one and he puts up a finger, right?
And one of the other kids starts laughing
and cause he's got an older brother
who told them what it means.
So he tells me what he means.
So they start shouting this
out, right? And this word,
they start shouting and well a couple of
the older kids, well by any here, here,
these three kids know six year olds
yelling and laughing up. Roy is like,
cause I think it's the funniest
stuck in thing they've ever heard.
And so they get called into the principal.
Well what happens next?
I have to find out about this,
right?
So now they notify the parents and know
in middle of the principal's laughing
when they,
when they're telling the story.
But now I have to have a conversation
with Mugsy when, when I come home.
So I come home and I said, monkey,
anything happened today? And he goes, Nah,
nothing happened. And you walked right
by me. And I said, wait, wait, wait,
come back here. I said, did you get called
into the principal's? He goes, oh yeah.
He said, we were, let me see.
We were playing on the
playground and I went like this.
And you know what this means? I said, no,
I don't need to know.
And I look out of the corner of my eye,
see his two older brothers,
like around the corner just waiting
because they know he's gonna get his ass
kicked right for, for this. And they're
just like, they can't wait. And so I said,
no, I don't need to know what it is.
Just don't do it again. Whatever you do,
don't do it again. And he goes, no, no,
no, no. You got to know what this means.
He's really intent on it. And so I said,
and he's two other boys skirts. I go,
they're like, oh, he's going to get
so much it. And I said, all right,
what does it mean? And I had no
idea what he was going to say,
but what he did say was mother Fucker,
and that's what they were
yelling on the playground.
All three of them at
the top of their lungs,
Gel mother fuckers six that's
six years old. That's a door.
And I started laughing and the
two other boys walked away,
disgusted that I was laughing.
And that's the end of my story.
So they're great kids.
So how do you take that gene?
You put it back in the
bottle, do you know? You know,
you just say don't use it all started
screaming motherfucker and there,
there's not much you can do. Throwing
their finger up in there. It's hard to do.
I mean, I find myself having to constantly
catch myself. I'll, I'll say, you know,
things like, hey, you'll quit jackass
and around, and then I'll think, okay,
I probably shouldn't say that, but
that's fun. I can't get, you know,
my dad was the greatest guy I've ever
known in my life and he swore and I,
it didn't scare me in any way.
I don't have a problem with it.
It's part of what I do for a living.
But when I was a wa I was, we were in,
we were skiing with my, uh, youngest
daughter who was three and a,
we're packing up the stuff and she forgot
to pack her helmet and a helmet wasn't
packed in the thing.
And she looks down at her luggage.
She looks down at the helm and she goes,
Oh shit,
this is something adorable.
But she was three at the time,
about a three year old sage. Let's see
if she could get together with Mugsy.
Then she could have said Shit and you
could have said what happened and she
could said,
I forgot my mother fucking helmet.
Then she's got a completely sentenced.
I mean,
there's something really cute about
kid's swearing. It's just adorable.
We try to tell them, you
know, don't, don't, yeah, we
try to teach him the basics.
Don't swear. If you can have,
the problem is they're going to,
it seems so attractive.
You know what to do because
they're not supposed to do it.
And when no one's around,
like, you know what I heard,
I remember I found a new word starts with
a C. Yeah. Oh, you know they're doing it.
Yeah. What's that one?
Oh God, yeah. Well, we,
we learned everything we learned
from older brothers. Right?
Or from friends who had older
brothers, but it was, it
was a slower process, right.
Because we didn't have the internet
and all that crap. Right. And,
and so I think what you,
you learned a lot. It took a
little bit longer. You know,
to learn,
like,
I don't think I've really
rolled out douchebag till I
was probably 12, maybe 13.
Well, we were talking yesterday about, um,
access to the Internet where kids see so
much more and hear so much more today.
Like there especially like violent images
and their access to terrible things.
And there's just so much that if you
leave a kid alone with a computer or a
phone that's online, oh yeah. Yeah.
They're just going to find out everything
about the world way before the little
brains are ready. No, you can't do
it. You've got it. You've gotta be,
you gotta lock it down, right. I mean,
it's a good thing they got
to learn the technology,
unlike what I apparently
would, I apparently did.
I'm gonna leave my, my, uh,
my watch here for you since I don't
know how to use it, but a year,
are you going to let them get online?